as Mara the capital of Eritrea I can't
get over my astonishment all around me
beautiful buildings from the Italian
colonial era cinemas mosques a
futuristic filling station very
different from other African cities at
the weekend people don't just worship
they indulge in what's called the third
religion here next to Islam and
Christianity bicycling easy yeah
something like imprison with air I've
come here with mixed feelings
journalists aren't welcome here it took
months to get a visa
there's no roaming to other mobile phone
networks so I'm unreachable it's a
completely unfamiliar feeling as Mara is
clean there's scarcely any traffic and
the climate is pleasant yet Eritrea has
been called the African North Korea from
which an estimated 2,000 people flee
every month
Eritrea's president Isaiah self-work he
was once seen as a ray of hope now the
West considers him one of the most
authoritarian heads of state in Africa
in a conversation at the foreign
ministry the international community and
especially the US are presented in a
negative light we're allowed to shoot
footage but not to use the conversation
as an interview the idea of comparing
Eritrea to North Korea is met with
indignation faced with the question of
why so many people flee I'm told Europe
and the US are at fault for luring them
away it's not the first time Eritrea
fled abroad during the 30-year war
against Ethiopia many did so after
Eritrean independence in 1993 some
returned the arataura German cultural
center was founded back then for people
returning from Germany alexander
se-young teaches german at the center's
language school his pupils are young
eretrians who are interested in germany
as they tell me cautiously three of the
young women are married to eretrians who
live in germany so they'll soon be
allowed to emigrate
it's a highly developed country I want
to continue my education there and I
think I can live better there than here
sein grew up in Wuppertal in germany
he's been back in Eritrea for ten years
but still feels German you know Mali of
to a necessity no more ordinary
eretrians it's normal to live like this
give me that you know what it's not
normal for me I grew up differently
Watson have a different mentality a
different way of thinking more
democratic and you have to tolerate some
things you get so much money do you for
instance the fact that there's no press
freedom the city is full of satellite
dishes with unlimited reception of
international channels but in Eritrea as
a whole there's just one newspaper and
one government TV station the average
annual income is the equivalent of about
600 euros lower than almost anywhere
else in the world against the beautiful
backdrop of Asmara
extreme poverty prevails everywhere on
the streets people try to earn a bit of
extra money many resort to begging
I try to talk to a few passers-by but
it's almost impossible as soon as they
see the camera people seem to be too
frightened to indulge in even harmless
conversation I'm told that to understand
Eretria you have to understand the war I
visit a tank graveyard discarded scrap
from the war of independence against
ethiopia eritrea still feels threatened
by its neighbor that's why the strict
military service every Eritrean has to
complete after finishing school can last
for decades virtually without pay it's
also why a very high portion of
eretrians get refugee status in Europe
but I'm told that no one leaves just
because of that
the country's disastrous economic
situation is an additional factor hardly
anything is produced in Eritrea itself
the raw materials for the state-run
brewery are imported officially the
brewery operates around the clock
despite shortages of water and
electricity I noticed that it's mainly
older men who work here men who by our
standards would have retired long ago
the brewery manager explains to me the
absence of young workers because they an
are not very much attracted to join us
because of the celerity our salaries are
I mean not quite attractive in the
monetary we have younger people there
because we have a better salary scale
there mustn we have elderly workers and
they are the most disciplined there's
quite a different average age at the
Dolce Vita shirt factory the only
private factory in Eritrea more than 500
people work in the Italian run plant
they earn more than the country's
average wage
manager Pietro Samba ET is well aware of
the migration problem employees are
constantly leaving he wants to try to
keep them by providing better wages and
social benefits but he understands why
so many go things are not changing at
the moment but I'm sure that as I say
the things can change if probably they
also need help they need trust the
European government they should really
open and I think that other cases around
the world have shown that only through
development comes democracy and the
people grow and cannot camera by force
for anything this beautiful country
provides me with plenty of food for
thought
I sense despair fear and resignation
lurking beneath the unblemished surface
but no one would admit that publicly
presumably during my state hundreds more
have left Eritrea